how did you end up bringing was that  Andrew J Bruning or anything was that  the first time you brought Andrew on uh  that he had him on your show yeah he um  someone from his team reached out to me  he's on Instagram so I was like I don't  know how I  um but yeah and I'd kind of messaged  with him about coming on the show before  he got banned  um and then Brittany Renner I just  thought of I was like I would be  interesting to have them on the same  panel so how'd you get out of London I  flew her out really that's what you do  just reach out to people like I'm gonna  fly you out you flew the top G yeah no  you got a private plane right yeah like  I'll get you some gas yeah I don't even  think I can afford the gas I'll get you  a flight to London I can't wow